bruno pomart ancien policier du raid
police nationale auteur du livre flic
d'élite dans les cités bonsoir
bruno pomart merci d'être avec nous sur
rt france bon bilan aujourd'hui pour la
police on sait qu'il y avait une
nouvelle doctrine est dictée par gérald
darmanin en tout cas en terme de
maintien de l'ordre
les commerçants en tout cas nous on dit
sur notre antenne qu'ils étaient très
contents il n'y a pas eu de casse
aujourd'hui qu'en pensez vous bah
écoutez d'abord des propos modérés du
préfet de police qui avait des propos
beaucoup plus fort sur les dernières
manifestations que nous avons connus qui
était ultra violente
là je pense que la nouvelle doctrine qui
a été initiée par gérald darmanin est en
train de porter ses fruits effectivement
alors à même de temps effectivement
cette manifestation n'a pas eu le le
succès que caisse côté les le moment
j'ai des gens évidemment puisque on
compte entre 3 et 4000 avoir servi le
manifestant mais je pense que compte
tenu du nombre de policiers engagés sur
ce dispositif je pense aux crs
évidemment et aux gardes mobiles en
particulier mais également aux unités
des bras 140 oeuvres avaient été
mobilisés plus les compagnies de
sécurisation des ratios je pense que le
métier de landes a été fort bien assuré
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'interpellations
en amont c'est ça la clé de la réussite
oui oui le pré filtrage qui a été fait
ce matin a été déterminant même temps
pour désarmer certains qui venait
effectivement non pas pour manifester
mais pour en découdre avec les forces de
l'ordre s'étaient c'était évident donc
le travail en amont a été très bien fait
à travers ce prêt filtrage et concernant
le maintien de l'ordre et qui a suivi
effectivement ça a été fort bien
maîtrisée parce que les forces de
l'ordre étaient à mende
alors c'était une journée test pour les
gilet jaune une journée test également
pour gérald darmanin at il réussi le
test selon vous écoutez oui il faut il
faut avouer que ça a fonctionné
y a pas eu de dégradations majeures
comme on a connu sur d'autres
manifestations ça c'est important
et encore une fois je pense que les
effectifs utiliser l'on planté à voler
sien à savoir que les braves sont
intervenus en marge des manifestations
pour interpeller des éléments les plus
perturbateurs et ceux qui méritent
d'être réprimée comme on dit dans ce
cadre l'aps qui viennent non pas pour
manifester mais pour s'affronter au
ans de langue ce qui est inadmissible
évidemment et encore une fois le travail
des crs et des gendarmes mobiles qui a
été exemplaire très professionnel et je
pense que c'est une première pour gérald
darmanin une première manifestation
je dirais réussi pour pour le
gouvernement qu'est-ce qui fait cette
réussite
concrètement est-ce que c'est là la
retenue qu'on demande aux policiers
avant cette manifestation
ce sont les ordres en quelque sorte
qu'ils sont donnés ou est-ce justement
le la doctrine le fait d'utiliser des
grenades de désencerclement moins
dangereuse le fait d'avoir des
superviseurs pour les ailes bd où le
nombre de policiers par rapport au
nombre de manifestants c'est quoi c'est
quoi le concrètement ce qui a porté ses
fruits
le nouvelle doctrine c'est une chose
quant à l'utilisation des grenades de
désencerclement quant à l'utilisation du
lb des comme l'a précisé le le préfet de
police effectivement c'est une c'est une
donne ça comme on dit mais je pense
encore une fois que le nombre de
policiers et le quadrillage qui a été
effectué pour éviter que les poussées
débordements a été bien fait tout
simplement je pense que le même temps
les policiers sont malheureusement
habitués à tous ces dispositifs et ont
su réagir correctement alors c'est vrai
qu'à alors déchargé effectivement le
nombre de manifestations n'étaient pas
très très de manifestants par dont il
n'était pas très important l'écho qu'il
en soit je pense a été menée
parfaitement parlée par les unités de
d'intervention qui étaient qui étaient
présentes bon alors il faut attendre la
fin de la soirée parce que ça a l'air de
raccords de bouger j'ai eu des des
collègues qui sont sur le terrain encore
pour beke encore une fois pour
interpeller les derniers même pas
manifestants mais les derniers voyous
qui sont là pour effectivement essayé de
casser et d'essayer de remonter sur les
champs-elysées ou sur d'autres secteurs
cc voyons comme vous les appelez ce sont
les fameux black blocks on a vu des gens
cagoulés effectivement dans les cortèges
est ce que ces gens là sont
véritablement arrêtés et punis ont pas
écoutés il ya eu plus de 200
interpellations qui ont été qui a été
fait par les policiers donc c'est pas
rien des gardes à vue
en conséquence oui encore une fois ces
éléments là encore une fois ne viennent
pas pour le
le projet d'humour barre des mouvements
j'ai les jambes ils viennent simplement
pour casser et en même temps tout ça
évidemment est de parler
ce mouvement de gilet jaune et qui soit
à faire passer des messages évidemment
est ce qui est ce qui est dommageable et
évidemment pour pour la société en
général
alors on a vu dans le cortège
aujourd'hui d'autres personnes un pas
que dd gilet jaune ces personnes dont
les gilet jaune d'ailleurs ont aussi
changé d'attitude
il déclare les manifestations en
préfecture il respecte les tracés selon
vous à part quelques éléments bien sûr
alors les tracés et fit quéven seront
mieux s'en firent d'accord avec la
préfecture de police mais pour avoir
débattu il ya quelques jours sur une
autre chaîne de télévision avec avec
jérôme rodriguez
effectivement il a eu une réunion avec
la préfecture de police et est le
message que je lui avais fait passer moi
puisqu'on a on a eu un débat quelque peu
houleux par rapport aux propos qu'il a
eu vis-à-vis du gouvernement et en
traitant la police de nazis et en même
temps les propos qu'il a eu à l'encontre
de jean-marie bigard bien il est revenu
un petit peu sur ses positions et
effectivement il ya un dialogue qui
s'est effectuée entre la préfecture de
police et des représentants de cette
manifestation c'est une bonne chose je
pense que à partir du moment où cette
manifestation trouvera un cadre légal
organisés en 4 d je pense qu l'irap vers
beaucoup moins deux problématiques qu'on
a connus sur les premières
manifestations
merci beaucoup bruno pomart pour votre
analyse je rappelle que vous êtes donc
anciens policiers du raid et auteur du
livre flic d'élite dans les cités et qui
est paru aux éditions anne carrière
merci